[Musica]
sì sì sì certo bla bla bla bla bla bla
mi sto pagando un po sotto per una vita
che non giocavo a un gioco this land
airmen nuovo fatto bene quindi può a un
mi sembra che si è trovata un pò nel
2011 quindi facciamo questo commentare
come se fossi nel 2011 non ha una per
carità scherzavo tarda eta area erdo
hardware dire duro attuali del cappello
area e area quindi cappello duro area
tutte le attività sono visitate la
videocamera canon ha permesso sono molto
contento di portare superman ragazzi c'è
una pagina benissimo con la madonna che
bello ragazzi ha fatto benissimo
bellissimo poteva uscire tipo 45 anni fa
suo gioco no adesso è disponibile nei
futuri update toccherà non è sbloccata
tutta la mappa perché questa è una pre è
un alpha version
vabbè avete vinto comunque dovrei
riuscire a trovare tutte le otto pagine
si spera non trovata già una quindi
teoricamente non sono i consulenti
dovrebbe oltre che puzzare farsi vedere
giorno per chi non conoscesse slider me
né probabilmente perché eravate un feto
quando è uscito primo da interventi che
discutibile slay interviene un gioco
dove c'è sto tizio mi sono visto il
gioco dove ci sto tizio qui che
praticamente ti deve prendere e non ti
deve toccare se non sei praticamente
morto e tu devi trovare chi è che questa
che visto che la puoi prenderlo 10 ai
due torce che due is meglio che one è
sempre così la cosa più bella di questo
slider man che però sento rumori che
rispetto agli altri che corri come si
deve il tuo personaggio corre quando
corre non come gli altri che mi
chiaramente che se fai un passo e poi
fai così c'è questa è la velocità media
degli artigiani giu
certo qua guarda con accordi bellissimo
così si corre di mortara li fece fare un
gioco dove si corre finalmente è sparso
e pieno di vito cecere mickey infarto
brutto salde ma in realtà non è così e
rata dovrei dovrei essere avvisato
dell'arrivo di slang un po in scurire lo
schermo dovrei sentire qualcuno che mi
segue no
così può infarto e crea caso va bene
rifacciamo madonna che in fare con
qualcuno ti becca l'infarto è molto più
pesante dello slider classico il
problema è che non vedo tizio e vabbè
allora borgo demonio sentito rami
spezzarsi bene ragazzi noi andiamo lì va
che bello 6 esausto ho finalmente mi
muovo come ecco questa però è la corsa
degli altri slam x men
in compenso una donna che ansia
marca walce camminare qualcomm e corre
negli altri meraviglioso porco demonio
ma poiché pronto prontissimo bruttissimo
veramente fatto bene ragazzi è fatto
benissimo
più che altro perché non lo vedi madonna
che brutto però mamma eva non vale e
vabbè puoi vincere il suo gioco solo dei
prossimi update praticamente già ma
scusa madonna che han siano affatto o
ragazzo bellissimo bellissimo fatto
veramente bene ma vedi che puoi
le pagine sono randomiche addirittura
quindi non sono tutte nello stesso posto
fantastico veramente splendido l'unica
roba e che dovrebbe avvisarti un po di
più quando ti sta inseguendo perché se
no
cos'è quella roba lì come lasciamo
perdere che se non vale c'è chi deve più
o meno dire a guarda chi c'è lo slang
sta per prendere no
tutto nei futuri update anche che
l'avviso che ti stanno uccidendo nei
futuri adesso non sa manco una pagina
quando non hai neanche una teoricamente
non dovrebbe mai beccarti quindi una
tattica degli altri slann dermer ragazzi
se qualcuno vuole avventurarsi sto già
con noi glielo consiglio ma nel caso era
andare a vedere un po dove erano tutte
le pagine poi prenderle perché sai già
dove sono capito tanto se non è presa
neanche uno in teoria non ti segue
signora non ne sto trovando manco una
quindi ottimo orco demonio che anzi non
ce n'è neanche una cioè dopo
completamente perse ma le hanno tolte
tutte non c'è neanche una pagina ma
veramente tutti i luoghi non lo trovate
prima non c'è neanche una ok non mi
sembra così grande stampa la poter me da
potersi permettere di non metterle lì
che è successo cosa ho visto chi è stato
ragazzi non si trova neanche mezza
pagina e che è ottimo ottimo proprio poi
c'è una scala che velo parole del si
riusciva a salire ma non si sale maraga
va neanche una come dove l'avete messe
cioè eccola o che allora uno l'ho
trovata non la prendo perché voglio
vedere un attivo dove sono gli altri
punti di interesse che sennò nov abbiamo
comunque impossibile ci sia così sia
così ristretta la mappa ce ne sono 8 no
malapena trovata una qua ce n'è un'altra
quasi ogni modo nella chi è ma scusami
ma scusami ma come ho fatto il giro non
ragazzi impossibile che ci siano otto
pagine sembra statisticamente
impossibile come fai a metterlo a meno
che non ne prendi una e poi una spola da
un'altra parte perché se non è strano
ecco la ride è cosa è successo
schiacciato un tasto che vi permette di
uscire dalla zona della demo però queste
zone qualche ci sono fuori dal tasso
sono zone non ancora completamente
sviluppate perché una demo ho capito ma
se le pagine beneventi qua io come
faccio a trovarle ma scusami era non è
giusto
sviluppa bene il gioco e poi elementi
non me le 20 quarta c tua città creato
una sua 8 dai faccio il giro
dall'esterno ma dov'è eccolo cori ma
corri madonna o quanto tempo percorsi
però e ascolti
ci sono le le robe che ti dovrei
spiegare perché non l'hai capito allora
quando tu guardi lo slider man lo slider
me si deve fermare
se no perdi per forza perché lui è più
veloce di te roge su ragazzi l'ultimo vi
prego l'ultimo tentativo perché
veramente infine bile ti spara in faccia
come se non ci fosse un domani e sei
morto cioè problema roba inconcepibile
però dai proviamoci
e allora se trovo si incontrò una demo
zon schiaccia il tasto per proseguire
tanto chissenefrega di qua non mi
ricordo neanche pilota l'altro l'ho
giocata da diciotto volte non mi ricordo
già più dov'erano le pagine poi si
registra casa non si sa mai suonata una
pagina incredibile una casa fatta è
l'unica roba fatta così bene e non ci a
spalla da una pagina porca vacca
sfruttano voglio fare un test e ragazzi
se adesso lui mi becca io provo a
correre col 100 per cento vediamo se con
il 100 per cento riesco a salvarmi
non lo so o meglio c'è qualcos'altro qua
eravamo vista sta roba credo buono anche
qua che sono edifici incredibile senza
la pagina porca vacca la metti la ma
cavoli si è fatto un bacio a fare
l'edificio fa karima 0 pagine sopra però
intanto mettiamo perché ovviamente le
pagine non si trovano a caso per terra
si trovano sempre in oggetti nel senso
oggetti costruiti tipo questo salve
madonna e quarrata il contrario se lo
guardi ti ti viene addosso il contrario
quelle del gioco normale non lo devi
guardare proprio con che al cento per
cento sto provando a scappare vediamo se
riesco non lo so è al cento per cento
sto scappando senza proprio
lo più di così non potevo scappare e
infatti mi sa che lo seminato ragazzi no
perché è veramente avevo tutta la barra
figurati se trova un'altra pagina o
impossibile
il problema è che devo guardarmi
veramente sempre in giro perché potrebbe
spuntarla ovunque ceppo di madonna mia
che brutta vista visione volevo di
revisione ma e roero traumatizzato verso
l'italiano mentre correvo mi è caduto il
dizionario di micro seminato impossibile
misura o almeno la tattica di tenersi
tutta la fatica sta sta funzionando
perché poi dopo un po scompare almeno
però il problema e vederlo perché mazza
ogni tanto l'obbedienza ai di fianco in
tanto vale che ti ammazzi ma anche ci
mancava un attimo che ti ammazzava pure
quindi è veramente difficile però store
esistendo più delle altre volte ragazzi
questa è molto meglio
immagino che i limiti tu non abbia messo
nulla se non saresti un pezzente sto
controllando pone limiti nella mappa
perché non ne sono sicuro così sta roba
c'è una specie di antenna what che non
ha niente dentro forse posso entrarci
proprio eccolo con lo spirito
all'interno io ho finito di vivere
conosco gioco basta veramente ben fatto
migliora alcune cose e siamo sul gioco
perfetto però mamma mia
c'è praticamente io ho giocato tanti
lander quanti ristoranti ha recensito
alessandro borghese che penso io posso
ribaltare il risultato la recensione dei
giochi this lander me quindi location
mettiamo un bel 7
anzi 8 prezzo di lei 10 visto che gratis
però ci sono dei bug degli insetti dei
bug nel piatto
quindi possiamo migliorare miglior amico
mio migliore io e nel frattempo ti
ringrazio per avermi accorciato la vita
di cinque o sei anni
a buon rendere amico mio spero che vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi scrive deve creare
lasciato un bel mi piace schiacciate la
campanina ritrovate vicino al bellissimo
i vostri scritti e noi come sempre
giriamo anche lo siamo visto bergamo
[Musica]